[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de 7,8 loisirs chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines et
tout le sommaire de cette semaine les
mérinos ne prennent pas de vacances à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet d
équipe vous attendent pour célébrer les
fêtes de fin d'année autour d'activités
créatives et de découverte des animaux
créer soi-même son sac à main grâce au
kit proposés par la boutique malice tout
le monde peut créer son propre cas bas
c'est la dernière idée cadeau de notre
calendrier de l'avent et l'agenda
complet de vos sorties au programme à
nouveau lieu culturel du cinéma est un
spectacle et ce nouveau lieu culturel
vient d'ouvrir à versailles fermé
pendant trois ans les carré saint-louis
ont été aménagés pour devenir un espace
dédié aux expositions un lieu construit
en 1766 pour accueillir abreuvoir
fontaines d'eau potable puis cabinet
d'architectes la première exposition est
à découvrir jusqu'au 28 décembre s
intéresse à saint-exupéry et dans cette
exposition sont proposés des dessins
originaux
ce sont les véritables planches de
l'artiste avec lesquels il a travaillé
pour faire donc ces trois volumes de
saint-exupéry on y retrouve évidemment
le monde de l'aviation
voilà tous les éléments autour de
saint-exupéry ils sont proposés à la
fois en dessin noir et blanc mais aussi
des illustrations couleur l'heure est
toujours à noël à saint quentin en
yvelines des animations sont à vivre
jusqu'au 4 janvier
attrape ce sont les traditionnels ferry
qui vous attendent ce samedi 21 décembre
dès 14 heures vous attendent un parcours
de sulky laser game et des déambulations
lumineuse les villes de guyancourt et
des clayes-sous-bois ont installées
chacune une patinoire alors chaussez vos
patins pour glisser en famille ou entre
amis et à montigny le bretonneux le club
saint quentin organise son spectacle de
noël le 21 décembre une crèche vivante
est organisée avant un chocolat chaud au
pied du sapin
on part maintenant pour rambouillet où
la bergerie vous a concocté tout un
programme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut encore patienter un tout petit
peu avant les vacances et les fêtes de
fin d'année mais la bergerie nationale
vous aident à attendre ces derniers
jours et on en parle avec emilie ruelle
vous êtes responsable de l'accueil au
mérinos café de la bergerie chez vous
les festivités ont même débuté dès le 4
décembre
oui depuis le 4 décembre on propose des
animations sur le thème des activités de
noël autour des animaux et autour de
petits ateliers créatifs et on a
également jusqu'au 24 décembre la visite
du père noël avait justement le père
noël il a trouvé du temps pour vous bah
oui il trouve un petit créneau tous les
jours aux alentours de 16h15 pour venir
nous rendre visite et puis récompensé
tous les enfants sages
parmi les animations proposées on est
dans l'une d'entre elles la crèche
illuminée de noël avec les zanimos qui
vivent à la bergerie tous les jours
voilà il ya une paix et un petit
assortiment va dire de des animaux qu'on
peut trouver à la bergerie et puis que
les enfants peuvent rencontrer dans
d'autres bâtiments
c'est le but c'est de les mettre en
scène dans un petit décor illuminé
et sur le thème de noël ce justement il
faut être aussi la découverte de la
bergerie c'est ça toute l'année on
découvre les animaux oui on découvre les
animaux on découvre l'endroit où ils
vivent
on peut également assister à la traite
des vaches tous les jours à 16h30 pour
voir un petit peu le quotidien de la vie
à la ferme
écoutez on est un peu différente
peut-être oui aussi bas nous se sert du
lait pour faire nos yaourts est
également propose un petit chocolat
chaud à la home et rhinos café pour les
visiteurs qui veulent se réchauffer
après avoir fait un petit tour de fermer
parce que c'est ça aussi à la bergerie
nationale c'est très gourmand voilà donc
nous on a un petit espace où les gens
peuvent venir se réchauffer manger une
crêpe et voir le chocolat chaud ou des
produits locaux or ceux de la bergerie
mais puisque à côté on a des noces café
on découvre des produits de certains
essayent aussi alors
nous c'est les produits de la bergerie
et les produits locaux on a des jus de
fruits bio on a des limonades on a des
biscuits qui sont fait également pas
très loin d'ici artisanale vous parlez
d'ateliers créatifs quelques petits des
ateliers créatifs jeux autour de la
laine ont fait des décorations de noël
ont laine donc ça peut être des pompons
ou des petites choses comme ça des
sables des coloriages où on met de la
laine dessus pour les plus petits c'est
adapté vraiment à tous les âges et tout
le monde peut venir s'amuser un petit
peu et puis il ya même un stage est 4,7
fois ces deux fois quatre jours et ça se
vient partir de 6 ans qu'est-ce que des
enfants ou pouvoir faire les enfants
vont pouvoir découvrir la vie du centre
équestre de la bergerie nationale donc
apprendre à s'occuper des fours
également à les monter et puis un petit
peu à s'occuper à s'occuper du matériel
et de tout ce qu'il ya autour des
chevaux tout découvrir
or alive devrait pas découvrir une
activité plus tard merci
emilie ruelles alors le noël à la
bergerie nationale se prolonge jusqu'au
5 janvier
vous pouvez ainsi prolonger aussi la
magie des vacances de noël
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le moment de retrouver notre
calendrier de l'avent depuis le mois de
début du mois de décembre nous vous
proposons des idées de décoration
cadeaux pour garnir le pied du sapin et
faire plaisir à vos proches
regardons ce que cache la case du jeudi
19 décembre dans le kit
on va retrouver le patron le patron
couture qui permet de faire le sac comme
avec ce sac ali dominique rey books
propose 35 modèles de kits tissu
extérieur tissu intérieure et la
maroquinerie dans un pack tout ce qu'il
faut pour créer soi-même son sac
une idée que cette créatrice saint
germanoise imagine il ya 20 ans j'avais
envie de transmettre aux couturières et
puis surtout je me suis attaché à
chercher les matières les matériaux qui
manque aux couturières il ya des modèles
pour les débutantes donc on va partir
effectivement sur des formes droites sur
des petits cabba et puis au fil des
années j'ai bien vu que les couturières
avait besoin de passer à des modèles
plus sophistiqués donc avec des choix
des tissus plus sophistiquées ou alors
des formes aussi arrondi avec des
fronces et c'est dominique propose
chaque année deux collections fonction
des saisons est décliné en plusieurs
couleurs
une gamme de prix entre 35 et 59 euros
passer d'abord par le vêtement dominique
se lance il ya 20 ans dans la création
de sacs à main
ça plaît à tout le monde n'y a pas de
problème de taille
la créativité sur deux sacs à main les
énormes les modèles parfois n'ont pas
bougé il est toujours des intemporels
jour des modèles très plébiscité mais ce
sont les tissus je vais changer cinq à
six modèles peuvent sortir de son
atelier chaque année des sacs de toutes
les tailles à peut-être offrir avec
malice un de ses proches c'est l'un des
jeux radiophoniques les plus anciens de
france depuis 1958 le jeu des mille
euros teste vos connaissances et votre
culture générale les émissions des 20 et
21 janvier vont être enregistrées à
magny les hameaux
ce vendredi 20 décembre les candidats
sont attendus dès 18h30 à la maison de
l'environnement au musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines vous pouvez
découvrir l'histoire de l'agglomération
mais aussi réalisé une maquette d'un
projet de ville c'est un atelier proposé
par les équipes prochain rendez vous le
jeudi 26 décembre
ce mercredi est sorti dans les salles le
dernier épisode de la dernière trilogie
de star wars un long métrage très
attendu nos jedi aurélie rond et
marylène gap ishino sont allés
recueillir les avis des tout premiers
spectateurs à l'ugc skywest je suis star
wars depuis 1977 quand j'ai vu le
premier épisode
donc j'étais au collège et aujourd'hui
je vois la fin de cette saga c'est
peut-être il fallait que l'histoire se
termine et elle se termine de façon
magnifique
e
quelle est leur aide et rei il y avait
beaucoup d'attentes sur ce qu'allait
faire ré en terme de ce qu'elle va
basculer du côté obscur ou pas moi j'ai
bien aimé la manière dont l'intrigué tu
es mené leur niveau mise en scène c'est
au top
évolution des personnages c'est au top
music au top aussi
donc si on n'a pas aimé le mythe on peut
quand même donner sa chance aux neuf
vaut mieux avoir aimé le set et avoir vu
le set au 6 mai faune y aller voir
regretterez pas et comme chaque semaine
on quitte un temps les yvelines via à
grand paris vous fait découvrir un
spectacle lauréat de plus de 25 prix
internationaux voire ans s'est présenté
pour la première fois en france un sujet
de paul wille ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre planétaire la
meilleure pièce de broadway en 2011
warhol traduisez cheval de guerre a déjà
été joué dans 12 pays
cette adaptation théâtrale du roman de
michael morpurgo est présenté pour la
première fois en france à la scène
musicale l'histoire un conte épique qui
se déroule pendant la première guerre
mondiale
le coeur de cette histoire c'est celle
d'un jeune cheval et sa relation avec
albert un garçon du sud ouest de
l'angleterre
l'animal est réquisitionnée par l'armée
et nous observons le voyage d'albert
vers la guerre pour essayer de leur
trouver une nouvelle fois je pense que
cette histoire parle et d'honnêteté de
l'innocence des animaux c'est une
histoire émouvante avec en toile de fond
ce conflit mondial
cette histoire va vous émouvoir vous
faire rire ou pleurer et vous partirez
en vous disant waouh quel incroyable
expérience
[Musique]
tu as oublié grande particularité du
show les animaux et plus précisément les
chevaux au coeur de cette histoire sont
des marionnettes animées par une
compagnie sud africaine
c'est un double défi interprétatif et
physique
j'aurai la star de war horse pèse 50
kilos il ne faut pas moins de trois
marionnettistes pour lui donner vie à un
accord montre la tête et les oreilles
alex et la mayonnaise de devant et marc
celle de derrière et il nous est
impossible de contrôler et de jouer tout
seul tout est question de communication
les uns avec les autres devront donc à
fondre à sentir les mouvements des
autres c'est la façon dont s'y dressent
en droit et d'abris politique c'est
vraiment très technique et c'est
probablement ce qu'il est plus difficile
war horse un show comme vous n'en avez
jamais vus c'est à lacets musicale
jusqu'au 29 décembre prochain et les
enfants l'attendent avec impatience nous
avons profité d'un marché de noël pour
rencontrer père noël il vous dit
quelques mots et bien les enfants il
faut avant tout être sage à vos pour
avoir plein de cadeaux à noël
et puis surtout noël est un moment où
ils fois partagé il faut partager la
joie le bonheur avec tous les membres de
sa famille et tous ses amis
et n'oubliez pas ne mangez pas trop de
chocolat non plus joyeux noël
c'est la fin du set 8 loisirs vous
pouvez revoir cette émission en replay
sur notre site internet et applications
mobiles
on se retrouve jeudi prochain à 18h30
sur cv soixante dix huit pour plus
d'idées sorties
[Musique]
il